you were a fully fledged lawyer like a
real lawyer like a lawyer yeah I was
like a lawyer not just a lawyer I was
like no but that's actually not true oh
it's like well it's mostly true I I went
through law school I got a honors law
degree I got a diploma in legal practice
I did my two years training to become a
lawyer and minus a week
and and I wasn't doing very well I hated
what I was doing I want to be an actor
and about a week before they slapped me
down they said this isn't really for you
is it you know this is not really what
you want to do go and and I became the
first trainee lawyer in the history of
the Scottish legal system to be fired so
I'm kind of proud of that but the next
day I packed my bags moved to London and
that was it that's I said this is in a
way I've been released to do what I want
to do